[Music]
[Music]
right it's time to kick this thing off
it's been two weeks since I read a
battlefield 5 you know what it's been
exciting it's been a lot of speculation
and so many brilliant remixes of a
reveal trailer but there's also been
lots and lots of questions from the
community and we've heard you you want
to see more gameplay innovations you
want to know how customization actually
works and we want to know more about our
take on the Second World War so today
we'll show you more gameplay and what
this is the deepest and most immersive
battlefield yes it certainly is you will
be able to dive and smash through
windows to surprise your enemies where
previously defenses were stationary you
will now be able to move these weapons
around on the battlefield and gain
advantages in our renowned destruction
system is back and more impactful than
ever so well you can't really hide from
those pesky tanks and more as they come
chasing you for you as they rip through
those buildings and you will now be able
to customise your soldiers your vehicles
and your weapons not only for the
gameplay but for the looks as part of
our portrayal of the second world wars
that's just the tip of the iceberg in
Belleview 5 you're going to see a lot
more of our new gameplay systems here at
EA play from our community so let's talk
about our single-player in war stories
yes let's do that
so we want to tell you about those
untold stories that got us excited to
start with on this game it's about what
you'll see is really those moments of
human heroism
it is about witnessing the world through
the eyes of the men and women who shaped
the world forever real and real and
relatable people facing the brutality of
war we started off by a exclusive look
at the new glace war story over at the
x-box briefing tomorrow thanks that's
something not to miss tomorrow
so a launching October is just the
beginning you will all go on an
expanding journey through the Second
World War
no loot boxes no premium pass every day
will bring something new and as part of
that journey after launch you'll get
something I know a lot of you have been
asking for mm-hmm it's Royale it's real
reimagined for Battlefield so we bring
those pillars of battlefield with
destruction team play vehicles into this
new experience so we will bring your
experience that you haven't played
before in battlefield or anywhere else
but more about that later this year so
with that it's time to show you what
makes Bal feel so special
it's the unmatched intensity /
multiplayer sandbox and this time it's
even more epic fighting across multiple
maps and modes welcome to your next
powerful experience and this is your
first look at ground operations at this
time even featuring music
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[ __ ] I ain't Harper
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
cuando era credenza simple singing
tonearm complain